so alan i do have to start with you
though um if i read that you were an
associate producer on black rain
in the early
90s late 80s yeah
how did that actually working on that
possibly help this with you know like
you know because you spent time in or
maybe you did i'm just curious
yeah well
my field in college was japanese
literature so i speak the language and
that's how i ended up working on black
rain because i wanted to work in film
and you always you have you have one
skill the other people don't have which
mine was speaking japanese i was able to
get a job with ridley scott working on
black rain
um i haven't made a film in japan since
then as you can tell that several
generations ago but still um
what's amazing is how much has not
changed and how much some of the same
situations we faced in production then
are the same situation situations that
jt and i faced this time
uh the show i believe is 10 episodes am
i wrong
this is m8
right so i'm very curious how did you
guys decide on the 8 was it an 8 was it
an hbo max thing like how did that
number get figured out i'll do that for
jt
well we were going to originally it was
going to be 10 and then
creatively basically one i shrunk for
creative reasons and then one was shrunk
for covert reasons but it turned out to
be creatively advantageous i mean the
thing that's fascinating about doing a
show of such length and
density is it it it tells you what it is
over time you come with a very clearly
idea of what you've created and what
you're making and and
much of that is at the same at the other
end but it it reveals itself to you
which is quite fascinating uh i know
that people are going to enjoy this show
and you sort of touched on it already
but as as someone who is already a fan
um are there plans for future seasons is
that the hope if this is a critically in
commercial hit well we'd love to i mean
i have you know i keep getting texts
almost weekly from actors and crew in
japan and around the world saying you
know when do we go back and i was like
it's not my call thank you for thinking
that it's the showrunner's goal
um we'd love to and i've got stories
ready to go but as is the case you know
understandably it's really up to
it's up to
folks how many people watch it and do
they seek more and you know we'd be
delighted to have the opportunity
you guys started shooting and it was
like five or ten days later you got shut
down with covid i've spoken to a lot of
filmmakers a lot of people that say that
that shutdown really helped them because
they were able to work on the scripts
they were able to just get things ready
did that actually help your show the the
shutdown
i mean from my end i'd love to hear alan
you too i mean from my end i i know and
i know talking number the actors on both
western and japanese who needed to learn
the other language fluently it was
immensely helpful uh so yeah i mean it
sounds sort of awful to say that that it
was helpful you know in the middle of a
pandemic but it certainly helped the
show i think would you agree alan yeah i
mean you get i mean
you know it used to be you'd make a
pilot and then you would wait and see
what you had done wrong and wait and see
if the network was going to pick it up
and now more often than not shows are
picked up straight to series so you
don't get to
make a pilot and then wait and correct
your mistakes so in this case we only
shot six days so it was a third of a
pilot but it still gave us a chance to
not for happy reasons but it gave us a
chance to reassess see what changes we
might want to make and also um just feel
more secure in knowing knowing what the
show was going back and then the the
biggest benefit as jt said was that
ansel continued to study japanese during
our shutdown so there was a quantum leap
in his ability he didn't have to
just you know mimic his lines in an
audio way by the time we came back he
actually knew what he was saying yeah
he's fantastic in the show i i was
really blown away by his ability with
japanese and um
he did a great job um i so i love
learning about like the behind the
scenes of the making of shows so for
both of you um what do you actually
think would surprise soon to be fans
of uh this series about the making of
the show
well i think that the one one thing is
that uh and i think you can tell is that
we
we went against everybody's conventional
wisdom and we made the entire show in
and around tokyo we shot 100 of it we
didn't build sets in another country we
didn't try to cheat vancouver or toronto
for tokyo and so i think when you're
watching there's i've had a couple
people say to me that it just feels so
authentic you feel every second of it
that you're in the city and that's by
design
yeah i think that i think what people
will be
uh hopefully surprised from tree by is
that you know this is built on the genre
of a crime show it is it's got sex it's
got violence got its mystery um
eroticism but it's character driven is
everything i try to do i make i try to
do and it's as i know allen is the same
and so
i think you'll i think people will be
pleasantly excited and surprised that
they're as they watch the episodes they
drawn in in some ways become almost many
experts in these worlds within worlds of
late 90s tokyo what is it like to
actually be a detective what is it like
to not just in a stylized way but in a
real way be a young yakuza japanese
gangster foot soldier struggling with is
this the life i want what does it say
about me and we begin to care what is
set up in the first episode to be we
think perhaps a show about this young
white westerner going through tokyo we
realized quickly as the show expands and
expands is actually just one of a larger
ensemble where in fact the majority of
the actors and stories we're following
are of japanese characters
when you were making a show about the
yakuza um
what is it actually like behind the
scenes in terms of uh are do you feel
like any do you know what i mean because
this is not an organization that likes
the limelight but many stories have been
told about the yakuza well i think what
we're doing i mean what do you think al
i think what we're doing is you know one
of the things i became fascinated wanted
to show in the writing of the scripts
and the directors into allen who you
know directed our finale being one of
them
really visually brought to life is you
know when you're behind the scenes it is
dangerous and sexy but also like you
gotta chop the onions everyone wears the
same strange by western standard strange
white jumpsuits and there's things that
are i mean this is a show that's funny
this is a show that's funny and
surprising and odd and wonderful ways as
well because
if you really get into any subculture
and explore it there's just wonderful
contradictions that come to the surface
i was going to say you know
we're we're not allowed to talk to real
yakuza but we had a number of ex yakuza
people who had successfully extricated
themselves from from the crime
syndicates who were with us as
consultants but the truth is there's a
huge genre of yakuza movies inside and
outside of japan but most mostly what
they do is they tend to glorify they
tend to look at this cool dangerous life
and instead it was important enough
important to us to say as jt says you
have to chop the onions the day-to-day
life is not so glamorous and that i
think you feel much closer to what
sato's life feels like because you're
able to see that it isn't all like
danger and fancy clothes and fast cars
that you're in a jumpsuit chopping
onions
uh i'm i i have more questions but i've
been given the wrap up side i'm just
gonna sorry i really it's all good i
want to say sincerely congrats i really
can't wait to watch the rest of the
episodes all right thank you steve
thanks so much